chinois
les chinois de chez nous les chinois
chinois et bassinois la presse chinoise
très bien que les plus jeunes y en
beaucoup plus joli surtout avec la de
tout comment on peut mettre même mettre
ça dans une soirée parce que regarder
ici c'est tellement je lis la forme
c'est ça tombe bien c'est bien quitter
trois heures de temps mais si je
remercie mao mao pas du tout et vous
offrons toute façon en france c'est
sûrement un mythe le péril jaune
je crois qu'on peut le dire moi
je suis très pacifiste et j'ai horreur
et j'ai beaucoup peur de commandes dit
de la dureté aux jeunes s'est appelé à
effacer la race blanche
sarko passablement le pressing liste
très pessimiste suggérait jeu je suis
d'accord avec les américains
au vietnam parce que je pense qu'ils
sont quand même arrivés à un certain
stade où on peut vraiment en avoir peur
chine - c'est parce que c'est des
chinois c'est des gens j'ai pas petit
jaune avec des yeux en amande qui sourit
toujours et qui sont qui parle
oui j'ai une moto sortait comme ça
entendre les parties à oui oui nous
sommes 47 47
oui emma ou venant parler entre vous mao
non pas du tout non c'est des jaunes
j'aime pas qu'on n'est pas les jeux je
déteste les jaunes la couleur
oui vous gêne pas de choses alors vous
réfutez tout en bloc
oui le petit livre rouge là même la
venue massive en rouge je me suis fait
ramené de hong kong a il est très beau
mais j'suis pas bon
parce que ça me fatigue mais parce qu'il
est écran chez moi aussi
ah oui écrit en chinois on est toutes
façons je les vols chinois certains
disent que les chinois viendront nous
bouffer c'est pas vrai il ce bouffon il
faut faire contre je ne me protège
c'est une faute très peur je pense à ce
qui va se passer plus tard parce que vu
avec leurs bombes tout ça vous voyez là
plein seulement vous voulez lâcher mais
c'est tout mais c'est j'ai passé ma ou
qui expose des idées tout à fait bizarre
mais qu'elle faisait pas il veut
exterminer peur oui mais la plupart du
temps moi je crois que les gens qui ont
répondu qu'ils avaient peur de la chine
ne savait pas de quoi il parlait mais
vous savez non mais j'attends de savoir
avant de dire que j'ai peur
[Musique]